cosa da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo lo ha sollecitato come una
scimmia perché ragazzi sarei uscito
destruction all star che sarebbe
teoricamente non lo so il nuovo rocket
dovrebbe essere perché lo sia di gioco è
molto simile solo con lo stesso re
nazionale va bene allora ragazzi sono
gasati tantissimo perché allora
l'abbiamo già provato però non insieme e
non invidio quindi spero di non fare
cagare io non me li ferrovia nati da
chio
allora ragazzi molto simile a rocket
solo che non ci sono le porte non c'è la
palla e non ci sono le macchine in
realtà non è il signor
oddio tu non hai idea di che cosa tu non
hai idea di che cosa società non hai
idea di che cosa è successo
non te lo saprei neanche spiega ho visto
una macchina in faccia però che non
succeda anche quando guidò la mia trova
l'obiettivo ragazzi diversamente da
rocker ma neanche troppo diversamente la
rocker e demolire gli altri
ok hai tu eccole vallo in quello non è
più che sono in ballo anche senza non
c'è la palla esatto infatti solo quello
ci mettessero la palla prevede un no
fermo la sua rovina non c'era nessuno in
macchina hanno singh che saltano sopra
dove sei
mi hanno distrutto la faccia e ma è
quello il problema sai come si fa
giocare in due non ti vedo ma guardiola
di strutture sono forte a posto niente
possiamo addio mi hanno scassato
vabbè allora quando ti distruggono la
macchina tu puoi uscire dalla macchina e
iniziare a correre come un puledro e
tentare di rubarla agli altri in questo
modo fa non l'ho trovata l'ho presa
semplicemente io sarei che in realta noi
non vinciamo spaccano delle autista
modalità mi sa e come si vince
dobbiamo prendere degli ingranaggi e
portarli nelle parti
ti sia per quello che sto facendo da al
minuto 1 immagine ma sto facendo
assolutamente niente di tutto questo ma
in macchina l'importante fa caos capisce
più e questo nessuno mi ha saltato a
iacolo togliti silos crollato lo scolo
lato ce l'ho fatta allora il discorso è
che sì ma io sono più fuori dalla
macchina che dentro c'è un casino ho
capito gli ingranaggi quando spacchi le
auto della gente ma cosa sto vedendo la
lasciamo perdere quello che vedono i
miei occhi che non saprei spiegarlo non
ho prove investire gente ce l'ho fatta
non ci sono dove sei che provo a
seguirti bravo a fare team non sa da chi
e dove chi la macchina ma milanisti dei
bagni la minima chi sta giocando per
quello ma chi sta giocando per le varie
viaggio come luci come call of duty
ammazzo la germania frega niente nelle
basi aspetta che entro in macchina qua
grazie sempre con la motosega gigante
che ammazza tutti ma chi ti sta vedendo
ho visto però possiamo giocare partite
diverse far finta di stare in tempo
vediamo lo so posso stare insieme con te
un attimo certamente la mappa io vedo
robben che non ti spiego ecco che ci
sono anche alla città ma che 26 di sé
quando si è sceso
ecco che il neonato eccoti eccoti solo
giorno la facciamo io da ragazzo c'è una
vecchia t ha preso parola diventa una
super tigre gara come corona ecco ecco
ecco di caco roba calcolava vedi qua
stanno invertendo veri che sta pagando
loro be mine quelle è me la immagino
perché se non avrebbe senso cag.are
recco c'è una macchina occhio nel salto
me ne vado non posso venire con te in
macchina qualche parte sconfitta che
strano perché lento dato anche bene
non so come abbiamo fatto a perdere c'è
uno che si chiama fuego che è un toro
banalmente è preso il
il diavolo ma perché mi sembrava cattivo
e quindi ho detto secondo me questo è un
po demolisce però avrò la macchina che
andrà lenta come la morte immagino
perché se non ha senso ma aveva la
macchina santelli inizierà prendi quello
che vuoi tu solo quando di quella di
tango proviamo la modalità di prima
ragazzi che a me non posso provare dove
rubare le altre a 5 infatti adesso dopo
giochiamo a calcio
ecco qua la macchina mia ti devi
togliere questa mia macchina gratuita
nel buco tutti siamo sono il diablo e vi
spacco tutti uno l'ho capito che gli ho
tolto un sacco di roba agli ami abbiano
tratto da solo cioè vabbè un genio
riesco a togliere un po di energia
questo qua
ecco fossi premio doveva il giro mi
chiedo disintegrati se fanno molto male
oddio l'aveva capi 2 e lui e lui terreno
dove lo prendo il mio d'aria che vale
aiuto
eccole morto ecco questi sono gli
ingrati
riprendo riprende il potuto fare un pò
l'ohio dovrà investire il tipo che è
uscito la macchina ha investito
l'investito 26 che non amano io questo
aspetto aspetta aspetta ospedale ok
consiglio gli ingranaggi e due li
consegno e nelle varie basi seno a b e c
ok rispetto al fatto un casino qua a b e
c ha però è avversaria un i no no no
lepre considera priori ma dove sbattere
sulla base ci vai dentro devi scegliere
l'auto devo scendere dall'auto di riley
perché sto facendo disastri aspetta
accumulo e poi ci vado ok ho anche la
specialità che questa non solo ma
attenzione madonna sto per distruggere
con altri in gravi ma dai ma che cosa
sto vedendo questo ho visto roba
incredibile
corri corri corri corri ho visto cose
che non saprei spiegare alla io c'ho
esco dalla macchina vengo a consegnare
ok non so cosa consegnato che nello
stato la mia special pack sono al fuoco
al fuoco va da fuoco vieni qui
eccola ce l'ho fatto ragazzi dopo due
ore dopo due ore su riuscito a salire
sulla
avversario e gli ho distrutto la
macchina adesso lo meno hanno già morto
eccolo qua lo volevo menare anche ma
questo e con lavoro farla dall'inizio
del video guardo rifaccio pure è
contento anch'io eh si questo
m'interessavo erano l'ho rifatto perché
ma scrollato per ora eccoci ci siamo di
nuovo ragazzi in the machine 26 st
voglio vedere se riesco a trovarti poi è
andata a ok io sono a a ok mi sono qua
calcio in fa la donna criminale a priori
gente per terra non si è accorto io le
su questo evitato che prendesse la
macchina aia porco demonio questo è come
quando mi demoliscono rocket che non te
lo aspetti per niente ok gli ingranaggi
gli ingranaggi con un meno di minuti ok
che pensa aver fatto un botto di punti
credo a morales i muri 9
ma che ne so io allora vuole presidi
vermelho ho fatto un disastro
ho ammazzato uno a caso aspetta che li
chi segue questo casino vabbè ma c'era
altra parte dell'ama panza arrivo marito
fortissimi non sa che cosa non so
neanche che cosa ho fatto in questi
bravi è esattamente così che si gioca in
un attimo quando un fatto che secondo me
ho fatto un punteggio spero almeno non
per ultimo ci sono andato male adesso
ciao ho giocato pure bene secondo me
sono per ultimo non sono per terzo
tentativo
bravo altro si è costretto gioco
incredibile consegnato quattro
ingranaggi solo quella volta lì
effettivamente poi basta gli altri non
hanno capito che non ha fatto nulla che
non hanno capito visione consegnare
ingranaggi ma sai che da solo o
presidente gli ingranaggi di tutta la
partita perché credo che nessuno l'ha
capito
esatto quindi perché abbia vinto grazie
a testa non vinceva io direi basta è
stato non si è capito una serie di
ragazzi spero che 26 cresciuto si chiede
a caratteri che quello che stai
affrettati vestita e acilia come sempre
ad un prossimo video di rocket league di
struzzo non stare o quello che è
sai che si rubino e si demoliscono le
macchine beh ragazzi
[Musica]